Die Pille wird dieses Jahr
60 Jahre alt.
1961 kam sie
in Deutschland auf den Markt
und war eine Riesenkontroverse.
"Ich lehne die Pille
für junge Mädchen ab."
"Sie automatisiert die Liebe
und versaut die Moral."
Gleichzeitig war sie ein Gamechanger,
ein Meilenstein
für die weibliche Selbstbestimmung
und sexuelle Freiheit.
Doch ihre Beliebtheit
ist jetzt seit Jahren rückläufig.
"Ich habe meine Pille abgesetzt."
"Ich dachte: Wie krass ist das denn?"
"Und das war tatsächlich
der erste Moment,
wo mir so richtig
bewusst geworden ist,
dass das Pillenehmen vielleicht
gar nicht so gute Idee ist."
"Ich hab die Pille
vor einiger Zeit abgesetzt,
weil sich die Nebenwirkungen
einfach so gehäuft haben."
Klar, Risiko und Nebenwirkungen
gibt's bei allen Medikamenten.
Aber sind sie bei der Pille
verhältnismäßig?
Was ist mit der Pille für den Mann?
Hier hört man oft
von einer klinischen Studie,
die wegen Nebenwirkungen
abgebrochen wurde.
Nebenwirkungen,
die bei der Pille für die Frau
allerdings akzeptiert werden.
Auch das wollen wir uns
heute genauer anschauen.
Außerdem hört man immer wieder,
die Pille würde heute gar nicht mehr
die Zulassung bekommen.
Wie muss man das verstehen?
Wir haben also einiges vor,
holt euch 'n Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich,
wir steigen durch.
So. Um zu verstehen,
wie die Antibabypille wirkt,
müssen wir erst mal verstehen,
wie der Menstruationszyklus
funktioniert.
In den Eierstöcken
liegen die Eizellen,
umgeben von Hüllen,
die man Follikel nennt.
Im Gehirn wird das
follikelstimulierende Hormon,
kurz FSH, ausgeschüttet.
Der Name ist Programm,
das Hormon stimuliert die Follikel,
die reifen heran
und produzieren das Hormon Östrogen.
Der steigende Östrogenspiegel
führt zum Aufbau
der Gebärmutterschleimhaut.
Dieses gut durchblutete Gewebekissen
ist notwendig,
damit sich eine Eizelle
im Falle einer Befruchtung
gut in der Gebärmutter
einnisten kann.
Wenn der Östrogenspiegel
einen gewissen Wert erreicht,
wird ein weiteres Hormon
ausgeschüttet:
LH steht für
"Luteinisierendes Hormon".
LH löst den Eisprung aus.
Eisprung heißt:
Die Eizelle verlässt ihren Follikel
und macht sich auf den Weg durch
den Eileiter in die Gebärmutter.
Und hier sind wir jetzt
in einem Zeitfenster
von zwölf bis 24 Stunden,
in dem die Eizelle
befruchtet werden kann.
Doch nicht nur
während dieses Zeitfensters
kann Sex zu Schwangerschaft führen,
sondern auch bis zu fünf Tage vorher,
weil Spermien so lange überleben
und auf ihren Einsatz warten können.
Der nach dem Eisprung
zurückbleibende Follikel
wird zum sogenannten Gelbkörper.
Der Gelbkörper hält einen
gewissen Östrogenspiegel aufrecht
und schüttet noch ein weiteres
Hormon aus: Progesteron.
Progesteron und Östrogen gemeinsam
hemmen nun die Ausschüttung
der Hormone FSH und LH.
In dieser Phase des Zyklus gibt es
keine weitere Follikelreifung.
Nach circa 14 Tagen
bildet sich der Gelbkörper zurück
und hört auf, Hormone auszuschütten.
Heißt: Östrogen- und
Progesteronspiegel fallen ab,
es kommt zur Abstoßung der
aufgebauten Gebärmutterschleimhaut,
sprich: zur Menstruation.
Denn ohne eine befruchtete Eizelle
braucht man dieses Kissen
zum Einnisten ja nicht mehr.
Und dann geht der ganze Zyklus
wieder von vorne los. So.
Wenn man jetzt
die Antibabypille nimmt,
passiert Folgendes.
Die klassische Antibabypille
enthält zwei Substanzen:
Hier gibt es unterschiedliche Arten
von Gestagenen,
die zum Einsatz kommen,
je nach Präparat.
Dieses Gestagene wirken
wie das körpereigene Progesteron,
das ebenfalls zur
Hormonfamilie der Gestagene gehört.
Solange die Pille eingenommen wird,
haben wir eine Situation wie hier:
Die Kombi aus Östrogen und Gestagen
hemmt die Ausschüttung
der Hormone FSH und LH.
Das heißt, die Situation,
die normalerweise
während der zweiten Hälfte des Zyklus
vorliegt,
herrscht jetzt durchgängig,
solange man die Pille nimmt.
Genau genommen passieren drei Dinge.
Erstens, die Reifung der Follikel
und der Eisprung werden verhindert.
Zweitens, die Gebärmutterschleimhaut
wird nicht gescheit aufgebaut,
sodass sich eine Eizelle da auch
nicht richtig einnisten könnte.
Und drittens,
das Gestagen sorgt dafür,
dass der Muttermund, der liegt hier,
durchgängig mit einem dicken
Schleimpfropfen verstopft ist,
sodass Spermien da nicht durchkommen.
Den gibt's normalerweise auch,
aber während eines normalen Zyklus
wird dieser Pfropfen
während der fruchtbaren Tage
dünn und durchlässig.
Und genau das wird eben
durch die Pille auch unterbunden.
Die Pille hat also eine Dreifach-
wirkung gegen Schwangerschaft.
Unter "der" Pille
versteht man normalerweise
das eben beschriebene Kombipräparat
aus Östrogen und Gestagen.
Doch diese Kombipille
hat sich in den 60 Jahren,
in denen es sie jetzt gibt,
auch weiterentwickelt,
und heute gibt es
Dutzende verschiedene Antibabypillen,
die sich in Zusammensetzung
und Konzentration unterscheiden.
Mit dem Ziel,
Nebenwirkungen zu reduzieren -
darauf gehen wir auch
gleich noch genauer ein -
wurde der Östrogengehalt
immer weiter reduziert.
Aber einer Östrogenmenge von
50 Mikrogramm oder weniger pro Pille
spricht man von einer "Mikropille".
Nur ist der Begriff "Mikropille"
eigentlich hinfällig geworden,
weil es heute kaum noch Pillen gibt,
die einen Östrogengehalt
von über 50 Mikrogramm haben.
Das heißt, die "Mikropille"
ist "die Pille" von heute.
Außerdem unterscheiden sich Pillen
wie gesagt
auch in der Art
der eingesetzten Gestagene.
Und dann gibt es noch
die "Minipille".
Die "Minipille"
enthält gar kein Östrogen,
sondern nur Gestagen.
Die "Minipille" ist also
ein sogenanntes Monopräparat,
kein Kombipräparat.
Aber die Go-to-Pille,
also "die Pille",
ist das Kombipräparat
aus Östrogen und Gestagen,
das ist also auch die Pille,
über die wir hier sprechen.
Und ja, diese Nomenklatur
mit "Minipille" und "Mikropille"
ist sehr verwirrend.
Deswegen gut, dass wir das
jetzt mal geklärt haben.
Die Wirksamkeit
einer Verhütungsmethode
wird oft mit dem sogenannten
Pearl-Index angegeben.
Der Pearl-Index besagt:
Kondome zum Beispiel
haben einen Pearl-Index von 2,
bei "perfect use",
also bei perfekt korrekter Nutzung.
In der Praxis kommt man nur
auf einen Pearl-Index von 18.
Die Pille hat bei "perfect use",
also unter Optimalbedingungen,
einen Pearl-Index von 0,3,
also ziemlich niedrig,
in der Praxis allerdings
nur einen von 9.
Wenn man zum Beispiel Durchfall hat
oder sich übergibt,
dann können die Hormone
im Zweifelsfall
nicht richtig aufgenommen werden.
Oder man vergisst
eine Einnahme einer Pille.
Grade wenn das
am Anfang des Zyklus passiert,
kann es trotzdem zum Eisprung kommen.
Deswegen:
Korrekte Anwendung ist essenziell
für eine wirksame Verhütung.
Trotzdem zählt die Pille im Vergleich
zu den wirksamsten
Verhütungsmethoden.
Aber:
"Zu Risiken und Nebenwirkungen
lesen Sie die Packungsbeilage."
Ich, äh, lass das hier mal
ein bisschen laufen,
da findet man nämlich einiges.
Das überrascht auch erst mal nicht,
denn Hormone haben nie
nur eine bestimmte Funktion,
sondern sind immer multifunktional
und sehr komplex.
Und obwohl diese Nebenwirkungen
in wissenschaftlichen Studien
beobachtet werden,
ist es schwer vorauszusagen,
mit welchem Nebenwirkungsprofil
man persönlich rechnen muss.
In der Praxis,
also in der Frauenarztpraxis,
wird das passendste Präparat
für eine individuelle Person
meist eher auf Basis von Erfahrung
oder Trial-and-Error ausgesucht,
was aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht
natürlich sehr unbefriedigend ist.
Doch die Erfahrungsberichte
sind nun einmal sehr individuell.
"Wenn ich die Pille nehme,
dann werde ich zur Furie."
"Starke Stimmungsschwankungen."
"Wegen jedem kleinen Bisschen
geheult."
"Manche nehmen zu, manche nehmen ab."
"Total zugenommen bzw.
es hat sich Wasser angelagert."
"Für mich war das schön, Brüste
sind gewachsen, Po ist gewachsen."
"Ich hatte Appetitlosigkeit,
und dadurch hab ich natürlich
abgenommen."
"Nachlassende Lust auf Sex."
"Ganz massiven Libidoverlust."
"Die Pille
erhöht das Risiko für Thrombose."
"Das ist kreuzgefährlich."
"Ich habe aufgrund der Einnahme
einer risikoreicheren Antibabypille
eine beidseitige Lungenembolie
erlitten
mit akutem Atem- und Herzstillstand
und war dann auch klinisch tot,
und konnte nur durch eine schwierige
und komplizierte Notoperation
gerettet werden."
Das erhöhte Thrombose-Risiko
ist die wohl schwerste Nebenwirkung,
da sie tödlich enden kann,
und in jeder Packungsbeilage
gibt es für Thrombosen
beziehungsweise Blutgerinnsel
einen Extra-Abschnitt,
zusätzlich zu den Nebenwirkungen.
Deswegen schauen wir uns das
mal genauer an.
Von einer Thrombose spricht man,
wenn Blut im Körper
zu Klumpen gerinnt.
Diese Verklumpungen
nennt man Thromben.
Es gibt venöse Thrombosen
und arterielle Thrombosen,
je nachdem, ob die Thromben
in Venen oder Arterien entstehen.
Die Venen führen das Blut
zum Herzen hin,
die Arterien vom Herz weg.
Normalerweise soll Blut
nur in Wunden gerinnen,
um die zu verschließen.
Wenn das im Körper passiert,
ist das sowieso schon mal nicht gut.
Besonders gefährlich wird es aber,
wenn die Thromben
vom Blut wieder mitgerissen werden
und woanders Gefäße verstopfen.
Das nennt man dann Thromboembolie.
Für Frauen "im gebärfähigen Alter",
die keine Pille nehmen,
liegt das Risiko
für venöse Thromboembolie
bei zwei von 10.000 Frauen pro Jahr.
Mit der Pille erhöht sich das Risiko
auf fünf bis sieben von 10.000 Frauen
pro Jahr.
Es ist also absolut gesehen
immer noch eine seltene Nebenwirkung,
aber im Vergleich zu keiner Pille
etwa eine Verdreifachung des Risikos.
Schuld daran ist in erster Linie
das Östrogen.
Die "Minipille" zum Beispiel,
die gar kein Östrogen enthält,
hat auch kein erhöhtes
Thrombose-Risiko.
Dafür aber andere Nebenwirkungen.
Und trotzdem wirken sich
auch die Gestagene
auf das Thrombose-Risiko
in den Kombipräparaten aus.
Man spricht hier manchmal auch von
den "Pillen der zweiten Generation".
Die Pillen der dritten oder vierten
Generation, also neuere Präparate:
Hier gilt also nicht:
"Je neuer, desto besser."
Falls ihr die Pille nehmt, könnt ihr
hier ja noch mal gegenchecken,
was für eine ihr habt.
Es gilt die "allgemeine" Empfehlung,
wenn man zum Beispiel
jetzt mit der Pille anfängt,
dass man eines der Präparate mit dem
niedrigsten Thrombose-Risiko nimmt.
Viele haben leider den Eindruck,
dass ihnen irgendeine random Pille
verschrieben wurde,
und fühlen sich nicht
ausreichend informiert.
"Da redet niemand
in der Schule drüber! Why?"
"Das heißt, deine Frauenärztin
hat dich überhaupt nicht informiert,
was die Nebenwirkungen angeht?"
- "Nee."
"Besser aufklären!"
"Denn ganz viel hat man uns Frauen
einfach nie gesagt!"
"Es stand nie
irgendwas anderes im Raum."
"Es war klar: Dann hast du hier
ein Rezept für die Pille. Punkt."
Doch die naheliegende Frage
ist jetzt natürlich,
warum wird überhaupt irgendetwas
anderes als das hier verschrieben?
Warum gibt es überhaupt
noch andere Pillen auf dem Markt
mit höherem Thromboserisiko?
Na ja, dafür gibt es
unterschiedliche Gründe.
Erst mal geht die Wirkung der Pille
ja über die Verhütung hinaus.
Manchen Frauen hilft die Pille
bei starken Menstruationsbeschwerden,
bei sehr starken Schmerzen.
Die Pille wird auch manchmal
gegen starke Körperbehaarung
oder starke Akne verschrieben.
Und solche Anwendungen, die geben
schon einen problematischen Anreiz.
Ich find's deswegen umso wichtiger,
gerade junge Frauen sehr sorgfältig
aufzuklären und zu informieren.
Denn als ich, keine Ahnung, 16 war,
hätte ich alles
für 'ne bessere Haut gemacht.
Scheiß auf die Packungsbeilage!
Deswegen muss man echt aufpassen.
Zurück zu
den unterschiedlichen Präparaten.
Es gibt auch noch andere
Nebenwirkungen außer Thromboserisiko.
Und Frauen haben offenbar
sehr individuelle Erfahrungen damit.
Und für manche Frauen mag eine Pille
mit niedrigerem Thromboserisiko
insgesamt
schlechter verträglich sein,
wenn andere Nebenwirkungen
dafür umso stärker reinhausen.
Wir sind hier jetzt aber
bei einem der größten Streitthemen
beim Thema "Pille".
Die Initiative "Risiko Pille"
zum Beispiel,
eine Initiativ Thrombosegeschädigter,
fordert unter anderem
den Verkaufsstopp von Pillen
mit höherem Risikopotenzial
für Thrombosen und Schlaganfälle.
Mehr Gedanken dazu
im letzten Kapitel dieses Videos.
Aber warum müssen sich eigentlich
nur Frauen damit rumschlagen?
Es gibt einen Ansatz
für die Pille für den Mann.
Oder für die "Pille",
denn es wird am Ende
wahrscheinlich keine Pille sein,
sondern entweder ein Gel,
das man sich zum Beispiel
täglich auf den Oberarm schmiert,
oder eine Spritze, die man sich
alle paar Wochen bis Monate
in den etwa Oberschenkel gibt.
Das Grundprinzip wäre aber ähnlich:
Nämlich eine hormonelle Verhütung,
die für die Dauer der Einnahme,
in das Fortpflanzungssystem
eingreift,
aber auch wieder back to normal geht,
wenn man mit der Einnahme aufhört.
Das Ziel bei der Pille
für den Mann ist es,
die Spermienanzahl
weit genug runterzufahren.
Nämlich auf unter eine Million
Spermien pro Milliliter Sperma.
Was immer noch sehr viel klingt,
aber nicht mehr ausreicht
für eine Schwangerschaft.
2016 gab es jetzt aber Schlagzeilen.
Eine klinische Studie
mit 320 Männern,
die eine solche Verhütungsspritze
testeten,
wurde vorzeitig abgebrochen
wegen der Nebenwirkungen.
Dabei waren die Nebenwirkungen
vergleichbar mit denen,
die auch in der Packungsbeilage
der Antibabypille stehen.
wenn nicht sogar insgesamt
weniger schwerwiegend.
Es waren dabei Stimmungsschwankungen,
Veränderungen der Libido,
Hautprobleme,
Schmerzen an der Einstichstelle.
Es waren insgesamt nur wenige Fälle
als schwere Nebenwirkungen
kategorisiert.
91 Prozent der Nebenwirkungen
wurden als mild,
99 Prozent als moderat festgehalten.
Das löste bei einigen Unverständnis
bis hin zu Wut aus.
Frauen sollen seit 60 Jahren
mit den Nebenwirkungen klarkommen.
Für Männer ist es zu viel verlangt?
Also, erst mal, der Studienabbruch
war tatsächlich
nicht so leicht nachvollziehbar.
Es war eine internationale Studie
mit zehn Testzentren
in unterschiedlichen Ländern.
Wenn man genau hinschaut,
gab es auffällige Häufungen
in einem dieser zehn Testzentren,
nämlich in dem in Indonesien.
Zum Beispiel wurden 62 der 65
gemeldeten psychischen Beschwerden
in Indonesien aufgenommen.
Auch 67 Prozent
der Schmerzen an der Einstichstelle
und 91 Prozent der Muskelschmerzen
sind diesem einen Testzentrum
in Indonesien zuzuordnen.
Wie gesagt, von insgesamt zehn.
Das heißt,
bei den restlichen neun Testzentren
waren die Nebenwirkungen
insgesamt deutlich niedriger.
Also mir sieht es eher danach aus,
als sei dieses eine Testzentrum
eine Art von Ausreißer.
Vielleicht wurden die Nebenwirkungen
dort anders zu Protokoll genommen.
Vielleicht gab es
irgendeine Besonderheit
mit den Probanden vor Ort.
Außerdem gab es zwei
unterschiedliche Ethikkommissionen.
Also die Ethikleute
in solchen klinischen Studien
sind unter anderem dafür zuständig,
zu beurteilen,
wann Nebenwirkungen
noch angemessen sind oder nicht.
Eine Ethikkommission
kam zu dem Schluss,
dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Die andere war aber der Meinung:
Diese Studie muss abgebrochen werden.
Also, es war auch nicht eindeutig.
Es ist also nicht fair,
aus diesem Studienabbruch
die Schlussfolgerung zu ziehen,
dass das Problem an ...
heulenden Männern liegt,
die keine Nebenwirkungen
akzeptieren können
und alles auf uns Frauen
schieben wollen.
Im Gegenteil,
die allermeisten Männer dieser Studie
hatten kein Problem
mit den Nebenwirkungen.
Und nur fünf Prozent gaben an,
dass sie diese Methode
nicht anwenden wollen.
Deckt sich übrigens auch
mit anderen Studienaussagen.
Für mich sieht es so aus,
als sei die Akzeptant bei Männern
für die Pille für den Mann
viel höher,
als es in vielen öffentlichen
Diskussionen erscheint.
"Verdammte Pille. Ich brauch dich."
"Unbedingt."
Die Forschung geht auch noch weiter.
Aber letztendlich, der Ansatz ist da,
die Nachfrage ist da.
Jetzt ...
jetzt macht doch mal bitte.
Wenn man drüber nachdenkt,
was gibt es denn noch an Verhütung,
das nicht auf Hormonen basiert,
fällt den meisten erst mal
nur das Kondom ein.
Aber es gibt noch mehr.
Wenn man als Mann
keine Kinder haben oder mehr möchte,
ist eine Vasektomie
eine einfache und risikoarme Option.
Nur nicht
so ohne Weiteres reversibel.
Es wird aber auch an reversiblen
Methoden gearbeitet und geforscht.
Zum Beispiel an einem Gel,
das den Samenleiter verschließt,
das bei Bedarf auch
wieder rausgespült werden kann.
Bei Frauen ist eine
vielleicht unterschätze Methode
die sogenannte
natürliche Familienplanung.
Hier bestimmt man
seine fruchtbaren Tage,
indem man Körpertemperatur
und Zervixschleim beobachtet.
Ihr erinnert euch
an diesen Schleimpfropfen.
Der Schleim wird
während der fruchtbaren Tage
ersichtlich dünnflüssiger.
Mehr dazu
in der Videobeschreibung.
Der Pearl-Index
der natürlichen Familienplanung
ist bei korrekter Anwendung,
also perfect use,
0,6 und im Real Life 1,8.
Nicht zu verwechseln
mit der Kalendermethode,
wo man seinen Zyklus trackt
und die fruchtbaren Tage ausrechnet.
Das ist ziemlich unsicher.
Man hört immer wieder,
dass die Pille heute
nicht mehr zugelassen werden würde.
Was viele
unter diesem Satz verstehen,
ist so was wie:
Die Pille dürfte
eigentlich gar nicht da sein.
Die hätte nie
zugelassen werden sollen.
Oder die Nebenwirkungen
sind so schlimm,
dass die heute damit
nicht mehr durchkommen würden,
aber weil die schon da ist,
haben die Hersteller
Glück gehabt und wir Frauen Pech.
So ist es aber nicht.
Ein Medikament,
das jetzt auf dem Markt ist,
und nach aktualisierten
Sicherheitsstandards
so schwere Nebenwirkungen hat,
dass eine Neuzulassung
daran scheitern würde,
würde natürlich auch
wieder vom Markt genommen werden
oder entsprechend
eingeschränkt werden.
Ganz falsch ist der Satz
allerdings auch nicht.
Weil zum Beispiel eine neue Pille,
die dieselben Nebenwirkungen hätte
wie die ursprünglichen Pillen,
die der ersten Generation,
heute es tatsächlich nicht mehr
auf den Markt schaffen würden,
weil es ja inzwischen
andere Präparate
mit besserem
Risiko-Nutzen-Verhältnis gibt.
Allgemeiner gesagt:
Ob ein Medikament zugelassen wird,
hängt auch von den
verfügbaren Alternativen ab.
Deswegen lenkt die Frage, würde die
Pille heute noch zugelassen werden,
eigentlich vom Kern ab.
Die relevante Frage ist:
Die Diskussion darüber
wird oft sehr emotional geführt,
was ich gut nachvollziehen kann,
weil eine objektive Beantwortung
nicht ganz einfach ist.
Aber es gibt drei Begriffe,
die helfen können,
das Ganze zu versachlichen:
Alle drei Kriterien sind
bei einem Medikament oder
einer medizinischen Maßnahme wichtig.
Doch meistens
reden wir nur über Wirksamkeit.
Sie steht zwar an erster Stelle.
Aber ein wirksames Medikament hat
nicht automatisch einen Nutzen.
Und was Nutzen hat,
ist nicht automatisch notwendig.
Also, lasst einmal durchsteigen.
Unter Wirksamkeit versteht man
die medizinische,
pharmakologische Wirkung.
Also bei der Pille
ist es die Verhütung,
aber auch Hilfe
gegen Menstruationsbeschwerden.
Dazu zählen aber auch
die Nebenwirkungen.
Und allein die Abwägung
Wirkung versus Nebenwirkung
ist von Mensch zu Mensch und von
Präparat zu Präparat unterschiedlich.
Zu Nutzen zählen Dinge
wie eine verbesserte Lebensqualität
oder, im Fall der Pille,
sexuelle Freiheit.
Und ihr seht hoffentlich schon,
so was wie objektiven
oder allgemeingültigen Nutzen
gibt es nicht.
Nutzen ist etwas sehr
Subjektives und Individuelles.
Bei einer medizinischen Maßnahme
spricht man von Notwendigkeit,
wenn zwei Dinge gegeben sind:
Sich darüber Gedanken zu machen
ist nicht nur hilfreich
für die persönliche Entscheidung:
Pille ja oder nein?
Oder auch für die Diskussion darüber,
welche Nebenwirkungen
vertretbar sind.
Sondern auch für die Diskussion
um die Pille für den Mann.
Was meint ihr?
Gibt es eine Notwendigkeit
für die Pille für den Mann?
Manche würden sagen ...
"Wär vielleicht schön, wenn's gibt."
"Aber von Notwendigkeit
kann man nicht sprechen,
denn es gibt ja
die Pille für die Frau."
Ich persönlich würde eher sagen:
Es gibt die Notwendigkeit,
denn es gibt kein anderes hormonelles
Verhütungsmittel für den Mann.
Aber das ist 'ne Meinungssache,
keine wissenschaftliche Frage.
Ihr seht, bei der Pille
geht es nicht nur
um Wirksamkeit und Nebenwirkungen,
sondern auch
um Nutzen und Notwendigkeit.
Und da kann man keine
allgemeingültigen Schlüsse ziehen.
Das ist vielleicht auch der Grund,
warum bei diesem Thema
so heftig gestritten wird.
Aber dann lasst doch versuchen,
das hier in den Kommentaren
konstruktiver und sachlicher
zu machen. Und zwar:
Wenn ihr Erfahrungen mit der Pille
habt und sie teilen möchtet,
dann teilt doch nicht nur
eure Wirksamkeitserfahrung,
also Wirkung und Nebenwirkungen
vor allem,
sondern teilt uns doch auch mit,
wie ihr persönlich Nutzen
und Notwendigkeit beurteilt.
Fänd ich sehr spannend.
In der Endcard
verlink ich euch ein Video
von unseren funk-Kollegen
von "Der Fall".
Es handelt sich hier
um den Fall einer jungen Frau,
die durch die Antibabypille
eine lebensgefährliche Lungenembolie
erlitten hat und gerichtlich
gegen den Hersteller Bayer kämpft.
Und von uns ein Video
über Antidepressiva.
Wir sehen uns bald.
Und bis dahin: Bleibt sicher!